with almost 500 sessions at next 2018
it's understandable that you didn't get
to them all so if you didn't see
real-time stream analytics with Google
Cloud dataflow common use cases and
patterns then stay tuned because here's
the rewind you might be asking yourself
what makes handling streaming data
different well when you've got lots of
data and I mean lots of data constantly
coming in
you can't just process it the same way
as a large batch data set we need to
make sure we handle the data
appropriately as it comes in
streaming analysis tools let us work
with unbounded data and handle
challenges such as unknown delays this
is especially common for mobile users
and devices that aren't always connected
late data will still need to factor into
your data processing in addition we
often want to work with grouping our
data into meaningful sets by factors
like time this is called windowing and
we can do this by dividing our events
into fixed time intervals sliding time
intervals or based on when a user is
active and sending events so knowing
some of the challenges that make
streaming analysis unique let's
implement an example if we were gonna
build a game with lots of events we can
use the Google Cloud dataflow and the
Apache beam SDK to do this we can
implement data processing with event
handling and we'll build a pipeline
using some common patterns first we'll
want to make sure we handle each event
while only once through exactly once
processing we can use Google cloud
pub/sub to handle all of the events but
we'll add in some DJ plication logic
right and data flow to avoid handling
the same event twice next we'll want to
make sure we can handle bad data that
comes in by default data flow will
continuously retry those records because
we don't want to lose data instead of
that
let's build in a system to handle
malformed data storing it in bigquery
for further analysis and setting up
alerts in Google Cloud functions now we
know that data won't be lost even when
we protect against bad data sometimes
additional data comes in but we actually
still want to capture it thankfully
bigquery allows for additive schema
changes if additional data comes in that
goes beyond our original schema we can
have bigquery update the fields without
any downtime and reinsert it of course
with all of that data there are other
parts of our architecture that might
have important information for our game
events in order to enrich our data with
some real-time denormalization
we'll add a step for grabbing data from
another source
such as BigTable during the data flow
processing will make a connection to
BigTable pull out the information we
need and then add that back into our
pipeline finally let's do some user
behavior analysis on our data now that
we've got all of our enriched data we
want to look at windowing our data with
sessions so that we know when the user
is playing the game also grouping by
user ID lets us fully analyze what
events a user generates during an
activity session now that is a streaming
analytic solution in the video Ryan
gives more detail about how you can
implement these as well as a great use
case from Sky a television provider in
Europe that saw some fantastic benefits
when switching from an on-prem solution
to using data flow and beam if you'd
like to see the full talk click on the
link in the description below
and don't forget to subscribe to the
cloud YouTube channel for more great
next rewind content thanks for watching
you
[Music]